this email comes from Bonnie Sexton  Bonnie writes I'm a huge fan four weeks  ago tomorrow  I received a kidney transplant after  being on dialysis for a year and being  on the transplant waiting list for two  years  so congratulations Donny by the way yeah  I named my new kidney Jacqueline Bouvier  kidney that's clever Jackie kidney yeah  she's a big fan of yours too this month  I've been listening to Hollywood  babble-on trying to heal and get my  strength back  can Kevin as negan wish Jackie kidney a  happy one-month birthday sure negan from  The Walking Dead sure you could do that  well well well  Jacqueline Bouvier kidney happy  [Music]  one-month birthday there we go negan  ladies and gentlemen Lucille warmed up  [Music]  you